you played uh d4
which you normally don't do and got a
pretty good position looked like you had
some great chances and finally fought to
this position and i don't know if you
know but the move rook c6 would have
been a winning move here played h5
quickly
uh your thoughts about
the game overall and in this moment
yeah i thought i was doing well
throughout the game i i did see this
rook c6 moment move but i thought it's
not
so what was cycle rook c6 okay you have
it on your screen
so right at this moment yeah it takes so
i thought rook c6 um your threat is to
play d6 and i understand so king f7
right yeah six rook g6
rogue g6
take
am i taking too many pawns
that's the plan
i'm assuming she's not taking yeah i
don't know no no wait kentucky
no that's too many pounds in
yeah she hasn't even taken one yet
you've already taken two
so
looks like you're going to get too many
pawns in this position but when i said
something i wasn't losing this wasn't
working out like this somehow hold on so
if i go rook c6 immediately
so she has to go king f7 right she has
no other moves
d6 i don't have there's no king is six
king six loses to d7
yeah i don't know
i didn't think i'm
i don't know
yeah i thought i have to go d7 so yeah i
guess i just don't have to go this sound
right i just take everything
yes exactly yeah
yeah such a pity i i didn't realize
that's um
i thought i had to i would be able to
break that fortress i didn't realize she
just defends her rook and i think i can
do
but i think it's a one temple thing at
that point because rook g4 and you go d6
you take on c5 sorry uh roxy and that
main line that we were just looking at
what uh
it's a one template i think so king six
six rook f3 or rook g4 we'll take c5 and
now the point is that you cannot take on
f4 first because of rook d5 right so you
have to take on d6 and then you lose f5
which defends also f4
and
oops
yeah but if i this has to be losing
yeah king b3 probably yeah right
and then you can even afford that
exchange
oh it's such a pity
chess is such a hard game and long you
had a long game yeah i just think if i
had a little more time i would have
found it
i mean of course it's always easy to
find it on that that's true yeah and
they say all rook and pawn endings are
drawn
but
sometimes it's just because of one
one move
still it was a terrific fight you seem
to have rided the ship in the last
maybe three games
more or less
okay i guess i scored fifty percent
fifty percent my last three games as
you're playing your your mood after the
rest day did what did you do to
to try to get your mood in the right
place
i just tried to forget the first half of
the tournament
and just feel like this tournament this
was like a separate tournament i lost my
20 rating points and just tried to start
over
all right well we'll let you get some
rest after such a long game good luck
tomorrow thanks a quick question for you
tata because you're making a transition
or at least today you played a mainline
nimzo indian as white where you really
have to know a lot of subtleties to get
an advantage out of the opening was this
line
uh uh here you she she had recaptured
on c3 yeah i i don't know this line you
did or didn't no because she doesn't
play okay i play names all with black so
i have some knowledge of the names like
surprised me i'm assuming it was her
preparation against someone else and
because normally she plays um
castles
instead of b6 okay gotcha gotcha all
right but okay i knew she could deviate
it's just hard and hard to predict when
exactly very loud
thank you good luck thank you
i'm looking at